[Musica]
oggi sono venuto qui a raccontarvi una
storia che ha più di duemila anni e
vorrei iniziare col mettere le mani
avanti
togliamoci il dente subito non conosco
il finale di questa storia
vedo delle facce preoccupate ormai è
tardi non potete cambiare mi dovete
sentire me però vi tranquillizzo subito
nessuno sulla faccia della terra
conosce il finale di questa storia
questo è sicuramente uno dei motivi per
cui questa storia così interessante ma
il motivo vero per cui sono qui a
raccontarvela con tanto tanto entusiasmo
è che è molto probabile che il finale
verrà scritto nei prossimi anni
nel corso delle nostre vite la
protagonista indiscussa di questa storia
la curiosità una curiosità di noi esseri
umani che abbiamo sempre cercato di
comprendere l'universo che ci circonda
questa curiosità si può riassumere in
una domanda in apparenza semplicissima
da che cosa è composto il nostro
universo
in particolare quali sono i mattoni
fondamentali a partire dai quali si può
costruire tutto dagli atomi alle
molecole a noi ha le sedie di questa
stanza a questo edificio pianeta terra
le stelle le galassie tutto
di sicuro non sono il primo che cerca di
rispondere questa domanda io lo faccio
per lavoro ma abbiamo evidenza storica
che già nell'antica grecia gli antichi
filosofi si ponevano esattamente la
stessa domanda è il più noto a tutti
forse democrito il quale per primo parlò
di atomi ma non fu l'unico ai suoi
colleghi avevano risposta diversa che
diceva l'acqua che diceva il fuoco che
diceva l'aria nonostante avessero
risposte diverse
avevano come un contratto comune nel
loro approccio nessuno si sognò
minimamente di verificare
sperimentalmente di aver ragione
e se uno non verifica sperimentalmente
la propria teoria è corretta o meno non
c'è modo di dire che aveva ragione e
quindi le cose rimasero bloccate per
circa duemila anni democrito vissuto
circa nel 400 avanti cristo e si
sbloccarono si iniziarono a sbloccare
circa nel 1500 grazie al grandissimo
galileo galilei italiano di cui dobbiamo
essere orgogliosi
il quale ci insegna come fare ricerca
scientifica ponendo l'enfasi su due
aspetti importantissimi
il primo l'uso della matematica nel
descrivere il linguaggio della natura
l'importanza della matematica ma il
secondo aspetto altrettanto importante
quello della verifica sperimentale è
importante avere idee e importante
essere creativi è importante dare
risposte ma ancora più importante esser
certi di aver ragione
e la ragione si ottiene verificando
sperimentalmente quello che uno ha
proposto galileo come ha detto visse nel
cavallo tra il xvi e xvii secolo le cose
rimasero bloccate ancora per qualche
secolo per arrivare alla prima risposta
quantitativa a questa domanda
dobbiamo arrivare al 1800 quando per la
prima volta vennero verificati
sperimentalmente gli atomi l'esistenza
degli atomi noi siamo certi che gli
atomi esistono a partire dal 1800 non da
prima sperimentalmente negli ultimi due
secoli
il progresso poi è stato inarrestabile
abbiamo a sua volta scoperto che l'atomo
struttura abbiamo scoperto anche la
struttura subnucleare sappiamo veramente
tutto dell'universo che osserviamo e il
progresso è culminato negli ultimi 50
anni dove abbiamo raggiunto una
comprensione unificata pazzesca
sappiamo che tutto l'universo che
osserviamo quindi a partire dai nuclei
degli atomi da me da voi dalle sedie
l'edificio i pianeti le stelle tutto è
composto dagli stessi mattoni
fondamentali che sono molto molto
piccoli sono delle particelle elementari
di cui conosciamo tutte le proprietà
benissimo e sappiamo le loro interazioni
quindi in apparenza abbiamo concluso la
nostra missione
quello che vi sto raccontando che tutto
l'universo visibile è compreso sappiamo
esattamente da che cosa ha fatto il
pavimento la sedia sappiamo tutto non
possiamo ancora dichiarare vittoria
perché la situazione in cui ci troviamo
oggi nel 2010 a 9 è riassunto da questa
questo diagramma a torta la materia
visibile dell'universo quindi gli atomi
e i suoi composti è soltanto il 15 per
cento della materia presente
nell'universo il rimanente 85 per cento
sappiamo che esiste ma non abbiamo idea
di che cosa sia
e questa materia non emette luce non
assorbe luce è a tutti gli effetti
invisibile ma sappiamo che c'è e per ora
per mancanza di nomi migliori gli diamo
il nome di materia oscura quindi
problema che ci troviamo ad affrontare
oggi è questo
e una domanda che può sorgere naturale a
tutti a chiese vicine al campo per la
prima volta chi sente parlare di queste
cose per la prima volta a me quando per
la prima volta mi avvicinai a questo a
questo problema come facciamo ad esser
certi che esiste qualcosa che non
possiamo vedere sembra strano mi sto
dicendo che sappiamo che esiste qualcosa
ma non lo vediamo in realtà abbiamo un
metodo infallibile per esser certi che
questa materia oscura esiste e sfrutta
una proprietà molto importante della
materia oscura ma trascura a massa
esattamente come abbiamo massa noi
comando massa alle particelle elementari
del mondo visibile e avendo massa
interagisce attraverso la forza di
gravità
ok quindi una particella di materia
oscura attrae una particella di materia
visibile perché entrambi hanno massa
sappiamo che due masse si attraggono e
in particolare a trendle e l'influenza
il moto quindi noi
osservando con molta attenzione il moto
degli oggetti visibili possiamo dedurne
le cause del suo moto usando le leggi
della meccanica
e quindi dedurre l'esistenza di qualcosa
anche se non lo vediamo perché ne
vediamo gli effetti vi darò un esempio a
breve per mettere tutto in una
prospettiva storica
il primo a parlare di materia oscura fu
questo signore un astronomo svizzero il
quale fece questo esercizio
studiò con molta attenzione il moto di
oggetto visibile in particolare di
ammassi di galassie e cominciò a dire
che c'era un problema
siamo negli anni trenta e negli anni
trenta alla qualità delle osservazioni
astronomiche non era affatto
paragonabile a quella odierna non ci si
poteva fidare più di tanto ma in
particolare diciamo anche che negli anni
trenta un'idea di qualcosa di invisibile
era un po un po folle non si era pronti
ad accettare qualcosa di così
rivoluzionario e per questo motivo
l'idea rimase dimenticata per circa 40
anni fino ad arrivare agli anni 70
questa strada ma nella figuraè vera
rubin la quale studiò le curve di
rotazione di galassia cosa intendo
questa foto è la foto di una galassia
molto simile alla nostra
noi viviamo nella galassia la via lattea
e diciamo questa foto è fatta da fuori
ovviamente vedete che la maggior parte
della luce è concentrata al centro ok
quindi andiamo in periferia la galassia
meno luminosa
questo vuol dire che la maggior parte
della materia visibile è concentrata nel
centro allora bra rubin osservò il moto
degli oggetti in periferia di questa
galassia e studiò come si muovevano con
che velocità si muovevano e l'effetto
atteso era di vedere che gli oggetti più
lontani si muovessero in modo più lento
perché perché stando più lontani erano
più lontani dal centro attrattore
subivano meno gravità e quindi dobbiamo
andare più lenti
l'effetto osservato fu sorprendente gli
oggetti distanti dal centro della
galassia si muovevano con velocità
costante
all'aumentare della distanza questo fu
un effetto sorprendente perché se io
guardo appunto oggetti più lontani e mi
aspetta una decrescita è la soluzione fu
che bisognava assumere l'ipotesi di
qualcosa di invisibile qualcosa che
fosse lì che desse la forza di gravità
in eccesso per spiegare questo modo
questo esempio ha una rilevanza in
prevalenza storica ok siamo negli anni
70 negli ultimi 30 40 anni abbiamo
accumulato evidenze di materia oscura
non solo sulle scale delle galassie
hamas tutte le scale non ci sono più
dubbi sull'esistenza di materia oscura e
quindi il fisico del xxi secolo si trova
a rispondere a una domanda diversa dai
nostri predecessori diversa da quella
degli antichi greci ma anche da da chi
ci ha preceduto un secolo fa la domanda
che ci poniamo oggi è da che cosa è
composta la materia oscura
questo è il problema che ci troviamo ad
affrontare oggi è questa domanda spinge
un'intensa attività di ricerca serie
tipo teorico e se di tipo sperimentale
allora l'attività di ricerca teorica
inizia più o meno così
questa è una foto che abbiamo scattato a
padova dove lavoro con dei miei
collaboratori
qualche settimana fa ci si trova di
fronte a una lavagna di fronte al market
del caffè dipende dai gusti di solito la
lavagna aiuta perché permette lo scambio
di idee anche scrivendo qualcosina
quindi solo parole a volte aiuta un
pochino scrivere e si inventa
letteralmente si inventano letteralmente
delle nuove teorie delle teorie volte a
proporre delle soluzioni al problema
della materia oscura e quello che si fa
e ci si confronta si cerca di avere
delle idee nuove e una volta che ci si
convince che l'idea ha senso si fanno
prima dei dei controlli preliminari che
possono essere fatti su una lavagna e
una volta assicurati che questa idea
forse vale la pena svilupparla ci si
rimbocca le maniche e si fa il lavoro
duro ci si chiude in ufficio
si lavora magari anche con l'aiuto di
computer per fare dei calcoli numerici
eccetera
e il risultato di questa operazione è
una pubblicazione un articolo
scientifico
però la cosa che vorrei infatti dare la
cosa importante tenendo a mente la
lezione di galileo è che quello che
questo articolo deve contenere sono le
predizioni per quello che ci aspettiamo
di vedere negli esperimenti se questa
idea corretta quindi il lavoro del
fisico teorico e oltre a suggerire le
idee deve anche predire le conseguenze
di queste idee alle conseguenze
sperimentali a questo punto passiamo la
palla i nostri colleghi sperimentali e
loro si trovano in una situazione in
apparenza difficile perché come ho detto
noi sappiamo che la materia oscura c'è
sappiamo che contribuisce alla massa per
un 85 per cento della massa totale
dell'universo ma non sappiamo che
proprietà che proprietà hanno queste
particelle non sappiamo che massa ogni
singola particella non sappiamo che tipo
di interazioni ha con noi quindi è molto
difficile disegnare l'esperimento che
sia l'approccio ottimale per scoprire
questo tipo di particelle quindi al
momento ci sono vari approcci sono fra
essi complementari e in questa fase
esploratori a vale la pena spingere su
tutte le direzioni
in questa foto ho messo tre esempi
quello a sinistra è l'acceleratore di
particelle del cern di ginevra
quello in mezzo ad un satellite che
rileva raggi cosmici i quali possono
essere prodotti da materia oscura e
infine nella figura di destra c'è una
foto dei laboratori nazionali del gran
sasso e vorrei spiegarvi un pochino
meglio quello che succede al gran sasso
non perché questo tipo di esperimenti
sia più importante degli altri
però mi è possibile spiegarvi cosa si fa
al gran sasso
un'analogia molto molto semplice presa
dalla vita di tutti i giorni
quindi mettiamoci qui questo e il gran
sasso vedete le due corsie
dell'autostrada nelle gallerie e queste
tubi sono i laboratori del gran sasso
dove ogni ogni stazione un esperimento
diverso ci sono esperimenti che non
ricercano solo materia oscura
però vorrei raccontarvi quello che fanno
gli esperimenti che cercano della
materia oscura qui un'analogia che ho è
molto semplice sono sicuri che tutti
avete giocato a biliardo meno una volta
non avete giocato sapete di che parlo
almeno qui lo scopo è molto semplice
vogliamo mettere la rossa in buca allora
che facciamo e prendiamo la stecca in
mano colpiamo la bianca che si mette in
movimento verso la rossa bianca colpire
alla rossa e se abbiamo fatto il colpo
bene ovviamente la bianca rincula in
direzione opposta e la rossa va verso la
buca quello che fanno gli esperimenti di
rivelazione diretta di materia oscura e
laboratori come la gran sasso è un urto
molto simile a quello che viene nel
biliardo
c'è una differenza importante che la
pallina bianca è una particella di
materia oscura
quindi due differenze da tener a mente
la prima è che è invisibile
quindi abbiamo una pallina bianca che
non vediamo questa è la prima differenza
la seconda differenza è che la pallina
che non possiamo mettere in moto noi non
vedendola ovviamente sarebbe difficile
quindi però sappiamo che ricordiamolo
esempio di vera rubin nella nostra
galassia è pieno di particelle di
materia scura è pieno di particelle di
materia oscura in questa stanza che
entrano dal muro non dalla porta passano
attraverso il muro passano attraverso i
nostri corpi non ce ne accorgiamo perché
sono molto debolmente interagenti ed
escono come se nulla fosse successo
così come entrano qui dentro possono
entrare dentro la roccia del gran sasso
e raggiungere l'esperimento dove
l'esperimento contiene l'equivalente
della pallina rossa la pallina rossa non
sono altro che dei nuclei che sono lì
fermi in attesa di essere colpiti e
quello che succede è un urto
completamente i denti con la differenza
è che la pallina bianca invisibile
quindi quello che noi vediamo è qualcosa
di fermo che inizia a muoversi senza
motivo
e siccome le cose iniziano a mai a
muovere senza motivo
noi diciamo che sono state colpite e
questo è un modo per scoprire la materia
oscura
al momento non esistono prove di materia
oscura da parte di esperimenti come
questo così come non esistono prove di
materia oscura da altri esperimenti
quindi la caccia
rimane aperta e al giorno d'oggi è
aperta più che mai
qui è dove ci troviamo nel 2019
ok sono più di duemila anni che
cerchiamo di capire il nostro universo
più di duemila anni e abbiamo capito in
cui 2000 che solo il 15 per cento è
molto difficile prevedere cosa ci
riserva il futuro
abbiamo visto che per capire un 15 per
cento ci sono voluti più di duemila anni
quindi immaginiamo per il resto ma
diciamo che il progresso scientifico non
è lineare nel tempo non è uniforme è
vero che ci è voluto tanto ma il
progresso è stato soprattutto negli
ultimi 50 anni
quindi è difficile quello che posso
dirvi è che c'è un'intensa attività di
ricerca sia dal punto di vista teorico
se sperimentale è una scoperta di
materia oscura nei prossimi anni non è
assolutamente impossibile anzi quello
che posso garantirvi è che stiamo
lavorando con grandissimo entusiasmo
nella vero l'opportunità di scrivere
questo importantissimo capitolo nel
libro della natura
grazie
[Applauso]